I, I don't wanna talk about the shitty heavy stuff.
I wanna tell you something super cool.
My daughter is a freshman in high school
and she fucking came home and told me. Mom,
did you know that my school does dual enrollment
and I can take college classes at the same time?
I'm going to high school and I can graduate high school with,
if not with my whole ass associate degree.
Damn near close to it.
And the college I wanna go to only has an 11% acceptance rate.
So I wanna make sure I can do everything I can do to get in.
And I could die happy. Jesus fuck! Oh my god.
That's like
the happiest thing I ever could have heard from my daughter.
She's not planning her fucking wedding.
She's not picking out baby names at 14.
She's looking up the acceptance rate
for the college she wants to get into
and right now making moves to make sure she can get there.
And I think part of why she does that
is cause she knows she's loved and supported.
And I don't know,
that felt like a huge fucking win. And I think
it's important to celebrate those wins.
And I like,
I.
I don't think I've ever felt that amount of love and pride in my heart
ever. For anything ever.
Like, I didn't know.
I didn't. I, man,
I just. I mean,
of course you dream that your kids are gonna Have dreams
and that they're gonna, like,
take steps to make those dreams happen and stuff.
But, like,
just. I don't know.
I don't know. That was like the coolest fucking thing ever.
And I just wanted to share it with the world
cause I'm so proud of her.
I'm so proud of her
and it. But, yeah.